[Music]
all right let's go to william in dayton
ohio with my regular voice what's up
brother how are we how we doing
doing good john how about yourself we
were we were partying in here man that's
not really true we're not we're just
hanging out drinking tea so what's up
man
well
a little background real quick i have
two children that come into my home
seven years ago uh they're my great
niece and nephew and the nephew is now
on well he just turned 12 and we're
having some disciplinary issues with him
and now he's starting even to dabble
into pornography
so how did he end up in your house man
well his parents were heroin addicts and
one night we got a call
that um they were going to be taken by
children's services so we said we're in
we'll take these kids what a study i
know
we're parents again you
know to be paroled from our kids
and
here we are again you know but it's like
you're empty nesters and then birds from
above just fell back into your nest and
you're like oh here we go hey high five
do you man
for not by your hand but in your lap
something a problem a challenge drops
itself in your front yard and you and
you married
yeah yeah me and my wife been married
now 17 years man you all stepped up and
said come on in and good for you guys
that's incredible where are is it your
brother or your brother-in-law your
sister
it's my nephew's children
my sister's son okay so yeah where are
where are they how are they doing
okay the mother we have no idea where
she is at this time um but the father he
is recovering from heroin he's been
clean for a year wow and we have slowly
been introducing him back into their
lives but it's been extremely careful
okay
good for them man
that's man
he's totally respected us as far as
parents go he doesn't try to jump up and
say hey i'm their dad i can say this and
i can do no whatever we say goes and he
respects us for that that's nice that's
incredible that's incredible that means
you're drawing great boundaries that
means even through his healing and
recovery he knows y'all were there for
him and for his kids
that's a family that speaks truth to
each other what i mean you're a model
for for for folks around so good for you
brother
so we've worked hard at it well it's
hard it is hard man it's hard work you
got to practice it it's tough so you
have a now uh 12 year old little boy and
then your daughter how old is she
she is eight
okay
so
12 year old is into into pornography
what you say there's some uh
there's some disciplinary issues what's
been going on
well i mean
i tell you that the boy will lie to you
when the truth sounds better
you know yeah just he you can't trust
what he says and we i mean we're almost
like helicopter parents to the extreme
because now when he says something
it's your homework now we have to go
back check everything make sure it's all
done because then he's going to fall
behind because it's not done yeah you
know and we we've even my wife even put
together like a clipboard list of them
things to do in the evening and in the
morning so they can stay on task with
their responsibilities and you can say
hey did you do your clipboard yep we did
it no they didn't you got it you got to
basically follow it around and make sure
it all gets done and i mean we're seven
years in and my wife and i we're we're
very
we're very proactive parents you know we
don't we're not the kind of parent that
threatens and then doesn't follow
through we absolutely believe that a
consequence has to come with a decision
that they make good or bad you know
there's there's something going to
happen
and you know if we feel like if we don't
follow through then we become liars to
the children and we're not going to do
that we're going to follow through they
know what's going to happen right
and you know that's just the way we've
always parented but like like i said
right now and and the boy
he's extremely intelligent he really is
i mean he's he's with the honor roll
last year
but this year he's decided to shut his
responsibilities
and you know we're not big video game
people and stuff we don't we don't allow
the kids to have free they don't have
cell phones they don't have ipads and
stuff and if they do use ours it's under
very strict supervision sure but you
know he would get up in the middle of
last film about a week ago about two
weeks ago he got up in the middle of the
night
he won the ipad and we found him in his
bedroom at 3am looking at porn
and i'm like you know and i understand
puberty i get all that but he and i've
tried to explain to him the dangers of
what he's messing with
and we're about to have the internet
just removed from our house we don't
need it you know i mean it's just it's
too dangerous it's like having a loaded
gun in the house there you go man
so
number one you nailed it
like i i don't begrudge a 12 year old
for wanting to see
naked people having sex
right he's 12 right so i i want to take
off he's not dysfunctional he's not
screwed up he's absolutely plugged in
normal i don't i don't it does that
doesn't get my heart rate up um even
figuring out a way at 3am to find it
you know if if back when you were a kid
if you knew your dad had a playboy
hidden somewhere in the house you'd wait
till 2 a.m and you'd try to find it
right so that that part you're
absolutely right that part doesn't
get my heart rate up
here's where you have the the the great
challenges it lies before you
a couple of them number one
these children their earliest memories
and when i say memories i don't mean
cognitive memories i mean memories that
have been encoded into their bodies
is one of addicts
heroin addicts opiate addicts who were
present but not present and probably no
one will ever fully understand what was
going on in those homes
and the homes they were in the homes
that their parents didn't show up and
they didn't come back home or they slept
for three days whatever that looked like
man we would probably never know what
those kids saw and or
experienced you're right what they do
know is that even when you're talking
about a heroin addict
it's very similar to alcoholic
your mom can be looking you in the eye
and be completely not present with you
or she can disappear in the house on the
couch for a day two days or three days
at a time
the word i'm getting at here that is
encoded into your child and you're into
the kids that you are raising is
disconnection
yeah and so
your son found some pseudo connection
through performance he made the honor
roll did all the stuff
he's also finding disconnection through
doing nothing
because you
still reach out to him you're still loud
you still hold him accountable and he's
seen
the only way through this road and it's
going to be hard you're talking neural
synapse
growth
it's going to take weeks and days and
months and years
is he has to understand that he is a
being of value and he's got a
participation role the house cannot
function without him
and he's gonna have to learn the weight
of what connection actually means
and for my my dad
i knew that he loved me
and when he gave me jobs and i didn't do
them
accountability and consequence look like
x your accountability and consequence is
gonna have to look different
here's what i mean by that have you
heard me talk about why i'm calling yeah
that's awesome hey it's awesome and hey
i don't get a lot of dads who say i love
my kid this much that i'm willing to
i've been running you know i was running
the run and shoot offense and it's not
working so can
is it a possibility we can run the ball
right that's rare that a dad does that
especially a dad on
on round two you know everything and
you're still
being humble enough to say is there
another way here man so i mean i'm
telling you you're a model for dads out
there good for you brother
well i thought i knew
i know i don't i learned a whole new
rule
[Laughter]
so
here here's what i did in my house okay
i'm going to tell you what i did in my
house
and you may have heard me say this
before and i'll say it a thousand times
again
is i went to and it sounds cheesy and it
sounds lame you can do this however it
works in your house when i was when my
kids were young young we did it one way
we're about to redo it and it will be a
lot more funny and we'll be a lot more
silly and winking at each other we'll be
a little more sarcastic about it but the
goal in the route is still the same
we went and got a canvas at
like uh michael's or one of those craft
stores crafts etc one of those kind of
stores
and you can use a two by four i don't i
mean i'm not two by four but like
plywood i don't care how you do it
but we sat together and we created the
delony family values here's who we are
and the kids got to speak into it we
tell the truth
we all have adventures we say yes we
treat each other with dignity we set up
from the floor up here's who we are
here's what it means to be a deloney
and then what i realized i was doing is
we'd be about to go fishing me and my
son about to go fishing he would not
have done his chores or something and
then i'd say well we're not going
fishing
and what i
because you did this i'm not taking you
fishing
and what i did was i began to weaponize
my relationship with him
if you don't do what i want
you don't have access to me
what i ended up doing now is i flipped
it
the same consequence happens if he
hasn't done his things
he knows that the house relies on a part
of the house functions because he's in
this family
and if he doesn't get his chores done
his stuff done that we agreed on would
have to happen before we go fishing my
language i point back to our values and
i tell him dude
man i'm choosing to be heartbroken today
because you opted out of going fishing
you didn't want to go with me
and you demonstrated that by x and y and
z
and what he learns in real quick fashion
i'm going to tell you it changed our
house
positively
as he grew to understand really quickly
that he has a he gets to choose
his behaviors he gets to choose his
thoughts and he gets to choose what
happens next
not me i'm not weaponizing my
relationship i want to go
but he opted out and when he's married
this is going to pay dividends when he's
going to college and he realizes oh i
chose to get an f because i chose not to
study
i chose to get fired from this job
because i chose not to
be on time i chose not to fill in the
blank
he's learning early on that he has a
role not that other people are just
going to be lobbing grenades at him
so
often children lie
they lie because they don't believe they
can
measure up
because there's a performative value to
the relationship in their home
or because they just get exhausted they
don't deal with it
they don't like the two-hour
conversations the
of or over the 20 questions the 40
questions the x and y's and these and so
what i want parents to do who've got
kids who are lying to him is really
simplify your message
you can't talk a 12 year old can't
comprehend all this stuff they're 12.
they can't do two hour three hour
marathon sessions they're 12.
what they can do very simply is hey as a
family we said we don't lie
i hate that you chose to lie man here's
x y and z here's what you chose
please consider choosing something else
tomorrow because we love you having you
around
in this house we treat each other with
dignity you're not going to swear at the
dinner table at somebody you're not
going to tell like my wife that you hate
her and that's coming by the way
as he figures out y'all aren't my
parents those are my parents i want to
go home all that kind of nonsense that's
that's coming down the down the pipe for
you
man i hate that you opted out of being
with us
hate that because we love having you
here you're a valued member of this
table
and so do you see how subtle this is the
same thing still happened but you are
letting him know this house rests on him
too he is a not fully he can't handle
that kind of weight but slowly over time
he's 12 13 15 17. he has to understand
oh man i've got strength this guy loves
me he's not going to lecture me he's not
going to try to talk to me all the time
but man he he counts on me and he leans
on me and i've got a choice in how this
thing runs
right
and here's where the the final dot dot
here's where this gets really hard for
you
he can opt out
he can opt
out and he's got to own those
consequences
he's got to own those choices but he
can't own him until you've trained him
on what owning looks like
once you train him on here's what
ownership looks like here's how this
works and remember you are regrowing
this young man's brain
because he's been through hell his
body's been through hell he's never been
connected to an adult he's done what
they say
he knows they're bigger than him and
more powerful than him and they provide
him food and a roof
but he's never been connected to one
yeah i agree
he uh
it's like he doesn't really
there's a trust issue there and i
understand why
you know and we just try to keep
building that bridge but he has such a
hard time of expressing he feels about
stuff so he he does not know how to put
it into word so here's what i want to
give you
um
i've had people write into this show and
tell me that they thought this was the
stupidest advice and it's been magic in
their home with their teenager i want
you to try it
i want you to
get a journal overspend on it get
something nice
and it's going to be just a
communication log between the two of you
and i want you to write him a note make
a commitment to write him a note it
could be two sentences it could be a
paragraph
every day i want you to write in there
to him and you leave it on his bed and
his job is to write something back
it can be don't want to talk
thank you
today was a good day
but i want you to write a couple of
things that you saw in him that day that
were great even if it's putting the
toothpaste cat back on
right whatever that is but he can see it
in writing he can hold it it's tangible
and what an addict's kid does is they
slough off the good stuff and they are
hyper alert for the bad stuff where am i
disconnected where am i going to get
left again
and when you write it down on a piece of
paper on and he holds and it's on his
bed when he goes in his room after
school and he sees it
man
that's good stuff that guy's still there
and his the rule is you got it right
back he can't just read it and throw it
on the floor he's got right back
and his job is to find a special place
in the house we can put it your wife can
set one up with him too maybe she does
one with your daughter
and by the way be vulnerable tell him i
had a hard day today
work was tough it was really i i didn't
want to get out of bed today let him
know what it's like because he's looking
at you as though you're perfect and
you're a drill sergeant and you are
running the show let him know hey man
this is hard i'm tired sometimes i don't
think i'm a very good dad
sometimes i want to be better for you
let him know those things and he's not
going to think he's crazy
if he will 30 second hugs every day
my son's almost 12 30 second hugs every
day
i ask his permission i don't i don't
like grab him and say no
and he's like
but we do it and it's big time
you think how can we slowly build
connection doesn't mean you'll let him
off the hook doesn't mean that you don't
hold him accountable you got to do those
things doesn't mean you don't quote
unquote punish him
you got to do those things
but the punishment is letting him know
god you opted out
i hate that
hey that you made this choice
please consider making a different
choice tomorrow because i want to go
fishing man
i want to go fishing with you
this house needs you
please consider rejoining us man
and then that night in that journal
so grateful for you i love you so glad
that you live in my house and that we
get to spend this time together
so glad god brought me to you
evoke the cosmos brother
and then william be grateful graceful
with yourself
be graceful with yourself man this kid's
got a hard row and his head and his
heart are different than yours and mine
i don't know i say i don't know if you
grew up with addiction or not but
he's got to learn what connection looks
like
and man if you get to a place where
you've got to take the uh internet out
of the house so be it you could probably
just take the ipads and lock them up in
your room put them under your bed or
something like that on if you take the
whole internet out but you're right the
internet's like having a loaded gun in
your house that's a great analogy man
um and good for you for being vigilant
good for you for being vigilant man
um don't beat your 11 or 12 year old up
for wanting to see naked people that's
normal
um your job is to stand in that gap and
take away as much access as possible and
by the way you can tell them
[Laughter]
to dad's everywhere you can tell your 12
year old you know what this is doing to
your mind and it sounds like the teacher
on charlie brown
naked people are awesome
and 12 year olds just not figuring that
out um
somebody just walked through the lobby
and i said that and they just looked at
me like ah this show got off the rails
um yes job is to stand in the gap for
your 12 year old access
it's your job to stand in the gap and
prohibit that man make sure they can't
get in get a hold of it i know it's
everywhere notes at school i know it's
on their friends phones
not in my house
thank you so so much for the call
william